bonjour eric revue merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ce matin en direct dans la
matinale de rtl france vous êtes chef du
service des urgences et du smur à
l'hôpital lariboisière
on a vu ce week-end ses premières
évacuations pensait ne plus revoir ces
images comment est-ce qu'on en est
arrivé là selon vous on en est arrivé là
de manière on va dire inéluctable
malheureusement on espérait sur la
première vague de mars dernière que
l'épidémie serait atteignez qu'on
arrivera à contrôler on a vraiment
l'impression que l'histoire se répète à
nouveau de la même manière avec la
conjonction un petit peu de plusieurs de
plusieurs facteurs effectivement le var
eu le variant du virus a probablement
aggraver les choses en terme de deux
vagues qui se présente c'est peut-être
aussi qu'on n'est pas assez vacciner
donc on est maintenant qu'on a les
moyens de le faire on devrait pouvoir
normalement arriver à mieux contrôler la
maladie alors toujours pas de
confinement en ile de france
néanmoins la question se pose le
professionnel de santé que vous êtes
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
j'en pense qu on a vraiment l'impression
de revivre la même chose que les
dernières on va dire en pire parce que
on en a autant la dernière nous avions
libéré l'hôpital pour ne prendre que des
patients qu'aux vide
là ce n'est plus le cas on a des
patients qui ont des pathologies non
qu'ovide educooo vide
encore une fois la vaccination devrait
nous empêcher d'être dans cette
situation là donc c'est un peu un petit
peu en colère que je vous dirais mais on
l'est malheureusement dans cette
situation là c'est extrêmement lourd
quand même de déplacer un malade en
terme de logistique
ça fait un an que l'on sait maintenant
que ce virus existent n'aurait-on pas pu
faire autrement
en ouvrant par exemple des délits
temporaire en réanimation
non je peux vous assurer encore une fois
que nous avons fait le maximum pour
contrôler la maladie et les services de
réanimation en ile-de-france de l'ap-hp
en france on a vraiment travaillé au
maximum pour éviter cette situation
donc on peut pas dire qu'on a été
parfait on apprend sans doute fait des
erreurs mais on a bien contrôlé quand
même cette maladie avec les moyens qu'on
avait je pense pas que ce soit
simplement une augmentation de lit qui
doivent le faire au niveau de la prise
en charge pour pour revenir ce que vous
vous disiez qu'est-ce qui a évolué
depuis un an
est-ce que vous avez acquis de
l'expérience qui vous permet de sauver
des vies aujourd'hui
oui bien sûr les patients sont traités
plus tôt sont identifiés ceux qui sont à
risque
les séjours se viennent plus court le
séjour en réanimation maintenant est un
petit peu plus élevée à cause du variant
parce que les hommes sont plus graves
mais sinon nous avons une prise en
charge qui etienne améliorée depuis
longtemps par contre les patientes un
profil différent à cause de ce variant
les personnes âgées sont maintenant pour
la plupart vacciner en ehpad
est ce que ça change aussi la lah
l'identité en tout cas des patients qui
sont en réanimation aujourd'hui oui bien
sûr le l'impact que ça peut avoir sur le
fait de d'avoir une diminution de la des
patients âgés avec des comorbidités qui
de ce fait diminue va permettre
d'améliorer
la prise en charge mais c'est vrai que
du coup on continue d'avoir des patients
jeunes qui se présentent avec le variant
anglais dans l'est dans les services
d'urgence et de réanimation des
nouvelles quand vous dites des patients
jeunes à quoi c'est dû est ce que il ya
plusieurs facteurs de comorbidité
également ou d'aggravation en tout cas
de lorca pourquoi plus jeunes selon vous
alors plus jeunes c'est vraiment il faut
nuancer c'est un petit peu dans l'âme en
dessous de 65 ans puisque c'était là la
tranche d'âge de 50 à 65 ans qui était
là la tranche de patients qui étaient
concernés on a eu des cas de patients de
30 à 40 ans effectivement avec ligue de
comorbidité certains n'avaient pas
forcément de commanditer et c'est pour
ça qu'on essaie d'enquêté pour deux pour
voir pourquoi il les avait ses formes
graves mais il ne reste que la majorité
des patients sont quand même des
patients âgés qui sont contaminés alors
les transferts devraient donc
s'accélérer cette semaine
oui les transferts devrait s'accélérer
alors il faut juste préciser parce qu'il
paraît qu'une bête petit cacophonie qui
est faite sur ces transferts il faut
être clair que nous faisons des
transferts en toute sécurité avec des
équipes de réanimation du samu qui sont
expérimentés que ce soit des transferts
qu'on fait avec l'accord des familles
bien évidemment avec une le contrat
effectivement lourde parce que ce sont
des patients qui sont lourds mais ce
sont des transferts on avait expérimenté
déjà un an mais qui se font de manière
nécessaire et donc pour vous au
contraire moi est ce que disent certains
scientifiques il n'a il n'y a pas lieu
de dirt confiner le week-end comme c'est
le cas dans certaines régions alors que
le taux d'incidents sa voisine quand
même les 400 hl à l'heure actuelle bon
pour être tout à fait honnête c'est vrai
qu'on n'est plus dans une décision qui
est plus politique que scientifique à ce
niveau là le confinement c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est compliqué
maintenant à définir essais j'ai pas
envie de donner mon opinion là dessus
parce qu'on a vraiment une
une vue je vous assure prendra la tête
dans le guidon tous les services
d'urgence et les réanimateurs sur le
nombre de cas qui se présentent
depuis un an on a eu des stratégies qui
ont été qui ont été faites je pense
qu'il faut davantage miser sur la
vaccination
ce sera à mon avis le seul moyen de nous
sortir de cette expérience
regardez encore ce qui se passe en
israël de 50 % de la population a été
vaccinée
il commence à revivre à nouveau de 7 et
sortir de cette épidémie
donc je pense qu'il faut plutôt suivre
ce modèle là merci beaucoup eric revue
pour votre témoignage le rappelle vous
êtes chef du service des urgences et du
smur à l'hôpital lariboisière